usually very difficult to spot but oh no
he is extremely angry is this loss now
yeah
yeah uh Wesley calculating extremely
well there
um it looks like he did give up a pawn
temporary Black's weak porn has actually
just dropped off the board but the
knights have disappeared at the same
time and
um oh look at Magnus he realizes this is
a blunder what's happening wow blundered
his Queen it took me a while to spot as
well that was visually very difficult to
spot but oh no he is extremely angry is
this lost now and this is where Wesley
Unleashed uh I mean Dynamite on the
board just brought his Rook across a
move that looks impossible again
sacrificing his Rook but suddenly Magnus
realized that white is dead lost if you
just capture this Rook then after Queen
takes Queen White cannot recapture The
Black Queen White here Rook up but there
is a deadly Checkmate on the board
White's King now trapped on its back
rank you can throw some Brooks in the
way but that king is not going to
survive black will just capture those
white Rooks and with this trick Wesley
so won the White Queen for just one rook
and guided it to Victory